hi thank you we're currently making fun
of our producer whose mother left when
he was uh
we're incorporating a bunch of songs
into what was going on when his mom left
his here yeah she loved a woman who
knows what she wants she left for uh I
guess a rabbi and never spoke to the
family again yeah it was a great thing
and now I'm sure she feels better for it
strong woman you know he checks in every
couple years does it affect her no I
just online I made a great choice she
checks on Facebook oh yeah no desire to
go yeah you don't think she regrets it
oh no you know they found that a
mother's love isn't helpful to a to a
child's growth so don't worry about it
no you're fine without it you're good to
go how are you I'm pretty good act like
I didn't see you two nights ago
I know hello hello Jim it's good to see
you it's good to see you
your movie is coming out and it's been
pushed up from June to now yeah why
don't they make it earlier why they make
it earlier can I sell unless I come and
show business yeah I just like my chance
come out early Oh movies in a theatre or
what have you so you've already filmed
it then huh yeah yeah oh no I love when
people say that or they you know they
walk by a set and they go is this out
yeah yeah you're seeing it right it's a
live movie yeah and then my friends on
SNL they go when is when it's does a
tape and they're like okay please get
away yeah honestly the test screenings
were going so well that they moved it up
that's great that's why I've never heard
of that before I haven't either I think
things are just so bad for women right
now they're like let's give one to
bagasse yeah do you think that's good do
you so it's like they're putting it out
you think it's a it's a woman positive
movie you think they wanted that old
earlier I do I do think that um but
that's based on nothing I also have no
information but I know that your
listeners are the target demo so right I
think of that when I was watching the
trailer I was like that's our listeners
don't like us either if it means
anything
yeah means the
I love your listeners I don't care and I
care what they say about me I love you
guys you know the criticism get I'm
watching a while I reach in for me I try
not to stay I try to stay away from
watch so I go through phases I look at
the app mentions that I don't look at
the admin
yeah the @ mentions that I don't look at
I uh never read a tweet and I think two
years did you feel better like then you
realize when you stop doing it you go
like oh that doesn't like because you
think it's this thing yeah like my my
like like you know my family my friends
like work that's real but yeah you're
like why it's like cutting yourself like
I don't really need to do once in a
while though now I don't I don't know I
don't like I can get that adrenaline
from other places yeah you well you
don't do it for a while yeah I kind of
feel like not that opinions are awful
but once a while I'm like I put too much
energy into it definitely I'm not doing
it I think as comics also like we really
want to we want to communicate we want
you to understand exactly we're saying
and so somebody misses it you you have
the urge to correct and whatever and has
enough immediate interaction anyway
every night you go on people are telling
me if I'm greater if I stinks okay I
don't really need you know I get enough
immediate yeah reaction from people
right well what I do is I say the joke
and then they don't laugh and then I
explain to them why it should have been
funny right and that's also what I do
with movies very helpful yes explanation
makes it so much better
Caligula you see Caligula where he does
some dumb joke and then he does this
reduce the hands like a plausibility
laughing clapping what a great life had
to be I picture Colin Quinn as Caligula
yeah I picture him is actually the guy
at the wedding getting the fist that's
how I picture Colin oh yeah happy uh
congratulate steuby married and people
are like how you Amy didn't do it was
just shortly
I would work here whose day Wednesday so
he wanted to be here for you guys that's
why I miss the way I'd love to have
taken off but I just didn't know why did
you tell about it last minute was it a
last-minute decision or did you just not
want it to leak it was a last-minute
decision like we knew we wanted to get
married for a while but then we were
like let's just do it
so were you everything were you engaged
yeah we got a prenup we did all the prep
yeah but we yeah so it wasn't like you
know on a whim how did he ask you um
really stunk isn't that good like you
don't want some cornball dude that's
gonna like have a good proposal like
damn like what'd you do so really nice
[Laughter]
that's right yeah no I he came in and I
was asleep it was the morning like it
was just like nothing and he handed me
the ring and he goes I got you this do
you want me to get on the knee and I was
like no did you cry
no Rebecca sleep yeah early yes the
morning we could have done this in the
afternoon so what went into the decision
of when you were gonna do it did you say
to him like let's just do it he asked
you okay so what what happened I haven't
said that yet we I was hanging out like
I was staying in LA at a house near
Jennifer Lawrence who lives right by
Adele and they're really good friends
and I never met her before so we like
hung out a little bit that week and then
we were just real drunk one night and
I'd and you know Chris when we were
talking about how we wanted to get
married and Adele was like well I can
marry you what if I tried to do her
accent well I can marry get like spot-on
I'm a dialect coach uh and we were like
okay cool and she was like and we were
making a whole plan we're like Tuesday
at noon because she you know she like
takes care of her own kid and whatever
and then and then like you know the next
day she's like hey we're not really like
friends and I think she got ordained
to marry her good friends I think she
was like they'll be kind of annoyed if I
just start marrying random basic [ __ ]
oh no so she backed out oh yeah it was
like a night it was like the next day
you know I was like a drunk it was late
yeah yeah and then we like you know
we're not like we're not like yeah she's
like I do not want you to have my phone
number
right right like I wanna go from the
other side I did not ask her oh I
actually did get her number but I
shouldn't I shouldn't never use them I'm
putting it in my phone as do not you
know you should write hello lol so then
we were like should we still get married
I'm 2 today we were like yeah let's just
who cares let's do it so there's no
drama like no planning it just seems
like it you know when you see your
friend go through planning a wedding it
just seems like it's so yeah yeah okay
everyone thought people everyone felt
like she's pregnant and you addressed
that pretty fast I know people always
just think I'm pregnant blame that
that's just my friend for life so Adele
said that she would marry and then when
she backed out you were like [ __ ] it
let's just do it anyway yeah and that
was the invitation process was just odd
text people i text people yeah yeah
there was no we actually never even made
like a cute little like flyer like a
text like we cordially invite no nothing
x3 everybody got a text say you want to
come to my wedding Tuesday yeah no can
do sorry so I wanted to talk to the boys
yeah if I said a little bit of notice
that what if I got hurt was fun I knew
would be a fun wedding - it was fine
blowout
yeah I got my dad you know a bunch of
money on invitations so right for the
point yeah all my girls from Long Island
uh you know my friends all I'm one plane
right yeah Keith Robinson yeah who else
we're the comedian's rather Keith mark
Normand I know yeah Rachel Feinstein um
it was Nikki on the plane I don't know
but the 80 Bryan Vanessa Bayer my Long
Island girls so you get married did you
have any second thoughts as you're doing
it or no no it was like the easiest
decision I've ever made it was like no
question
do you like it I mean it's brand-new but
have you met him I have you I
Thanksgiving house oh right so you know
we got a lock that down yeah yeah I was
yeah people are asking if I was pregnant
I should have like told him I was
pregnant so it can happen sooner
did you know immediately you wanted to
marry this guy no but after a couple
months did you specifically want to get
married in general or we know I've never
I've specifically not wanted to get
married yeah I think it's kind of weird
to involve the government in your love
life but I wanted to marry this this
[ __ ] yeah how did you discuss like
when you have to mention a prenup I
guess if you're together a long time
it's awkward but how do you mention it
do you just say hey look I think we
should do this or did he kind of know
and you both knew that you should do it
well he has money to live he's not rich
or anything but like it was like you
know he's a farm he's Lily Jurlique
let's let's get a prenup mm-hmm yeah
like okay here's I'm talking to my
lawyer today talking it was yeah easy it
was awkward
the lawyers go back and forth so it's
like almost like they're not even
involving you - the lawyers are just
talking back and forth or no it's a
weird stuff like they're like okay so
when you die you know like talk about
the will stuff for you like talking
about unborn children they're like you
know just thinking and you're like can
we wait that Furby yeah they're like
nama like they just go through every
scenario right because as soon as like
you get married and then all of a sudden
you have to do this and that's when all
the steps of your life start playing out
and go like okay so here's how
everything's gonna play out and you're
gonna be buried where and you're like
can we like have a glass of champagne
first all right
wasn't a hundred percent ready to tackle
my mortality exactly exactly so that was
weird just for both of us yeah it's
awkward because you got a legal counsel
involved and now like if there's
something that lawyer says it's like oh
[ __ ] is this coming from him or just
coming from her yeah it's like you're
having a discussion without having a
discussion
totally and that you know where do you
want your ashes spread and I'm just like
how about I do where did you say what
did you say you want them spread did you
ask right here in the studio you guys
thank you how long before the wedding
did you actually do the prenup week
we've been doing it for your hands
before they say you have to because like
you don't want to do it within a month
of getting married
because then the other person can claim
it to rest yeah you give yourself at
least a month you know you can't do it
like two days before the wedding or it
won't count yeah semantics prenup
signing it was kind of fun though
because we knew it meant we were getting
married yeah
right now we're actually gonna do this
yes we got we got the paper all this
trouble I think it puts less stress on
the marriage cuz you don't have to worry
like wait what if this happens am I
gonna lose this you already know where
you're at and now you just married you
don't start taking liked Olaf like off I
went now then he gets the garage right
did your mindset change at all that when
you got married like just in general
like I think sad stability yeah yeah so
like we've made a commitment we're
growing up soon we're starting a life
yeah yeah we were like psyched to get
that out of the way like have fun with
it but get it out of the way so we could
just start life yeah do you think you're
gonna have kids maybe I don't know not
right now
right there's no there's no regret like
oh no like what if I meet some and so
you know I mean like were you always
like [ __ ] if I meet this person or if I
meet someone he's like beyond my wildest
dreams really this guy he's such a good
dude yeah how did you meet his sister is
my assistant you didn't know that no
yeah you might have told me I forgot my
memory card you don't care about your
friends oh wow okay so how did you feel
about when you started dating her
brother yeah like in a very beginning
well I asked her if it was okay like for
us to even hook up and she was like
shouldn't wanna lose her job so she's
like yeah that's great she still your
assistant yeah dude you treat her better
now Chris now she's your sister-in-law
oh yeah yeah yeah they do get fired no I
mean we like already just our
relationship was like you know friends
and she was trashing me immediately like
she just all day is just like a look at
your raccoon hands she's like she's a
very mean-spirited person so we hit it
off right oh yeah I think you need that
right oh yeah she has zero respect for
me it's perfect
how long has she been your assistant no
no it must be longer than that
maybe almost like a
so you might obviously like it means a
lot to me six months in ten years
although we forgot like I you know my
dog yeah them I have a little dog Tati
and like my birthday and then yesterday
and then she was like oh it was two days
ago with the assistants I don't know you
always hear about people having like a
dog so I didn't even get really good
yeah that's awful people have dogs
parties and that dog is horrible right I
don't know what I would have done
different but I still got kind of shitty
I didn't like hamburger meat or
something like that it's your birthday
yeah [ __ ] I was right give a nice one
place how how long after you like you
meet him and she and she's your
assistant that you go I really like this
person was it immediate no no I knew him
for like I don't know six months before
we even like flirted at all it was just
I didn't we didn't look at each other
like that
honestly like he was so I thought he was
so hot and like such a romance novel way
that I was just like oh he's like sleeps
with models probably and like I just
discounted him like that and then we got
to know each other and I was like this
he's such a great guy I was just psyched
to be friends with him I just he already
felt like family yeah and then yeah and
then one night how much do you like a
guy who can cook because he really is
good I ate his food is amazing
there's there's nothing better I can't
even imagine this it's so awesome really
yes yes man remember when you liked it
well you don't ever have this experience
but you feel taken care of yeah yeah
that's good yeah women like a man who
can cook I've never cooked it my I've
been in my apartment for a year and a
half and I'm not kidding I still have a
cardboard in the stove shocking
absolutely no one in this room the
thought of you like even microwaving
something is weird to me I've used my
microwave 20 times I just order food
yeah my kitchen is not big but it's nice
it's nice for Steen yeah right oh wait I
haven't seen your new place I know I
know but that's just you've been invited
but you're away no that's you at my
wedding
I haven't had anybody over you never
Keith keeps told me to have comedians
over I've had one boy I forget I used
also not he's realistic yeah I'm not a
social person he had one thing in his
apartment for like all the guys at the
radio show yeah he says hosting exactly
don't touch my Ozzie sunglasses versus
first he instead of inviting the interns
he hired them to help with the food
you're really ambitious why I had them
over there I was paying them I was very
nice and then when I got there I
realized he was stressed about the
seating arrangements so he got those
fold-out canvas camping chairs with wood
cup holders in the are they [ __ ]
worse they were rotting somewhere and
there are you on the street and then he
asked people to take the chairs home
with them he didn't have a place to put
them the creepiest I give away camping
chairs most frightening serial killer
Home Depot to find is that cardi B cardi
Oh
cardi B is outside well I asked ya
thirty people with her do you know cardi
B Amy
oh yeah we're best friends right no we
don't know each other she's taller lady
than I would have thought is that right
yeah
oh okay there you go thank you yes
assumed I yelled yes that's her well she
was the girl doesn't front yeah okay
that's Heather from this way so yeah we
had camping chairs because I'm not a
good host but I have enough furniture
for a couple of people and I'm gonna
furniture for 12 P yes then explain the
duct tape and the chloroform we don't
need a [ __ ] chair for that a muffle
yells it's funny like I feel like we're
so comfortable at the cellar like till
we can just sit there and check around
for hours but as soon as it's out of
that environment it's like seeing a
teacher outside of school you're just
like ooh yeah it's really awkward well I
mean we traveled on the road together so
I feel like we're fine you hear but
being social you know yeah you know I am
weird with that stuff having
/ I'm very I'm just not a comfortable
person having people over like that and
socializing comedians is different
comedians right cuz I'm just spending
time out of yeah yeah I mean I mean
again on the road you're eating you're
doing all the social so you wouldn't
feel like you need to get camping chairs
if you were inviting a bunch of the
comics over yeah what if it was a shame
with a camping chair I'm calling the
police immediately
I need more furniture I don't have that
much furniture I'll have a few things my
partner Bob mattress whatever you used
to make mail bombs I did end up sitting
in one of the camping chairs and it was
comfortable and there was a spot for my
beverage which was nice but just way out
of place in a living room was it like
camping kind of like glamping it was
glamping
he sat outdoors it was fun it was a fun
time it was uh you have a good place you
have a bigger you have a bigger like
main area that I have so you have those
seats on the floor right which I love
yeah those are good yeah they're awesome
you just sit there look at the fireplace
yeah you don't have to like the room
isn't set up to interact yeah are you
handing out you were handing out these
candies and I almost ate one and I
didn't know what it was
really you were hitting drugs yeah yeah
just you know these gummy bears look
really good
I had no idea what it was you know you
want to come again I'm like yeah someone
let you have it you would have freak
they're super mild the ones I have
they're like you know someone asked
milord I just don't like oh I just loved
it you thought that he was just giving
you a gummy bear like don't you like a
gummy bear but it was a higher but it
was a high end candy so it didn't
surprise me that somebody walk around a
little box of weird candies Guardian
it's drugs yeah I didn't know that
would've been [ __ ] awful yeah I would
have got one for free though like a part
of me deep down after was a [ __ ] I wish
I didn't I actually hate that though
when you like ask someone if they want
like a joint or edible or some like that
and they're like they're like yeah and
then they put in their pocket you're
like doesn't like hang out it's not for
you to go home yes I said someone
handing you dessert and you just [ __ ] it
you like I'll take it to go see my
[ __ ] yeah really weird no it's really
yeah awful
bad etiquette it's like stealing what is
your movie about I know what it's about
but I have to ask you didn't watch the
trailer even yes but how else do you
promote a movie did anyone in here watch
the moon garbage people Thursdays the
screening I mean by - yes I am actually
liar I'm gonna be with awful friends but
no was Thursday was uh we didn't get a
copy to advance I watched the trailer I
know was about well you're like my dad I
play this girl with a really low
self-esteem and I'd like to thank your
listeners for and then she she hits her
head in a soul cycle class and she
becomes like she all of a sudden thinks
when she looks at me or she just sees
like Giselle like she just thinks she's
a supermodel and and so she kind of
starts living her life that way and then
you know her life like open things open
up for you when you feel good about
yourself but she thinks she looks
entirely different like she goes up to
her friends and goes like I know that
you're not gonna believe you like
recognize it's like it's it's like a
Freaky Friday type of movie and except
she does don't change body exactly the
same what's wrong with her yeah yeah
it's funny it's funny it must be nice to
walk aren't that kind of confidence just
that good-looking person it was fun
confidence just yeah just like being
Beyonce right yeah it was fun it was
good for my self-esteem just thinking
that everybody's flirting with you and
they're like one yeah just about
everything you think everyone's staring
at you and flirting with Rio and you're
just like and the girls are jealous of
you a lot anyways of all the people
because you're doing very well but all
the people who have you've spoken to or
met who's the one person who recognized
you who you were like [ __ ] you who
recognized me and I was like [ __ ]
Beyonce that didn't happen did it it did
we're when the Met Ball am I have I
changed
no not really no that's a beauty no
you're the same [ __ ] creep you're
coming to sell it on sweatpants and
[ __ ]
at the Met Ball and she was sitting
right across Ribble's our sisters across
me she was right like diagonal for me
and Solange
Solange was right across from me yeah
she was cool as hell so you met the
Knowles sisters I met the nulls y'all
and Beyonce was like are you having a
good time she's because it's your first
Met Ball and I was like it's my last Met
Ball giggles and I just couldn't be you
know and she was she was really nice she
sent me flowers once who you seated next
to he's not a big deal at that Met Ball
who they seat you next to and how close
you are to Anna Wintour am I thinking
the same thing yeah you're Biden and
Beyonce and Solange it must have been
good seeds yeah I had been invited to be
on on the like main thing like the board
or whatever but I couldn't but uh yeah
so I was sitting next to Hasan Minhaj
he's so funny like that dude and
Alexander Wang maybe that design you
allowed to bring a plus-one or no me no
you know what I was allowed that year um
but oh I was allowed like I both times
yeah but uh we had just broken up so I
said a grocery lalala
Anthony like we sat near each other and
while Anthony Carmelo Anthony's I mean
that's not her identity she's also a
badass but she did they are they done I
thought I don't know and we we can't we
we had a really good time we were both
like you know really broken up you came
into this Southern when I was Anna
Wintour and and you were going on after
I was and then she came in and sat at
the very end of my set I remember seeing
her walking I was doing such a [ __ ]
filthy I think about pulling like
pulling a cab lost when you're calm it
was just something really dirty [ __ ]
joke a very strange night at the but it
was funny to have this lady walk in and
oh my god humiliating yeah this is why
I'm where I am
are you comfortable those events are
know yeah I don't I mean no because you
know you meet enough famous people
you're like they're just like I like
being around comics I think we're the
best you know so it's like I'm not I
don't care about how anybody there feels
about me so it's just annoying to have
to dress up to that level of dressing up
because you know I like to be
comfortable and that's why I look like a
trash heap all the time you have to hire
if you have to hire someone to go look
this is what I want to look like or do
they just kind of you just picture you
like oh yeah like SEAL Team six like
bottle like comes in and just changes
you you can't just order a dress online
I don't know I don't think so but you
know those things like for me it's not
like you know it's not comfortable
I'd rather how come Beyonce sent you
flowers when I made that uh that
formation video oh yeah yeah good for
that I had gotten permission from her
she's like Goldie and I just want to
like make this thing and whatever and
and she sent me flowers and people get
people got mad at that they had no idea
that she had said it was cool with her
to do yeah but you know what it really
wasn't even about that it was just like
we just made this this thing um that we
were having Hawaii and like we were so
into that album and it was before the
election and we were just like I don't
know we just wanted to make like a thing
with all girls and that was that over
the summer and yeah and I don't know
I've been thinking about this a lot
lately I don't know that this is the the
venue for this but like I've always you
know I get accused of things that are
not true um and one of those things is
being racist and I realized that I'm not
racist I've always seen scene everybody
is totally equal that's the truth you
know but I wasn't doing enough I didn't
know how in other how little equality
there was not just for men and women but
for black people of color too and it
wasn't like I need to be doing stuff to
to make that better
like I it's not enough to just recognize
and go oh that's unfair I'm in a
position where I can like try to help
with that and so at what point did you
start to regret saying that in here as
soon as I started but did you start to
feel like you needed to be or wanted to
be socially conscious of things mmm you
but itself oh no no but I didn't you
know you start out you sonant be funny
and tell jokes and do well as a comic
no I mean maybe like before my first
hour special I did stuff about rape um
like how if she's asleep it's it's still
a no so that was like maybe the second
season of my TV show I realize like
people were listening and and people are
trying to sort of write about me like a
like a voice for women or whatever right
and uh and I rather than like be
burdened with that I looked at it as
like an opportunity and I was like oh I
can try and say things and try and make
it funny you know I would talk about
grape like gray area rape when it's not
like you being thrown in a bush and like
you know rape I like a homeless person
but if you know the guy whatever so I
like kind of then so maybe like I don't
know you should fires ago are you
surprised at the response people have
accepted being very angry if you take
one stance the other side just hates
your guts automatically I um I was
surprised by just the things that I just
see is being illogical like it's like I
want to get it it's a couples therapy
you know so what I when I would do work
with with every town for gun safety what
I'm saying is I think that uh just
people who are severely mentally ill or
are on the terrorist watch list
shouldn't or I've been convicted of
domestic abuse I don't think those
people should be able to get guns and
then you go like well what did you hear
when I just said that and they're like I
heard you wanted to take away all guns
right and you go okay that's not that's
not what I'm saying and they're like no
that is what you're saying and because
you know the NRA and like people have
they've done a good job because it's our
business of brainwashing the people that
they're keeping captive actually of
scaring them like well the government
might take your weapons like they've
never done or whatever it's one-sided
like if you're not completely for this
yeah you're there completely again
you're gonna take that and run with it
so it's so that surprised me how much
hate I got from like that from wanting
to make like you know more sensible gun
laws
people forget that you had a couple
people murdered - watching your movie
and it's like there's no more of our
personal connection when people are
watching at work you put together and
there are fans and you know that they
were killed watching
something you did yeah like if I hadn't
made that those girls would would be
alive like there's no getting over that
and just anyone who like you know gets
really annoyed with anybody in my
position that speaks up and like you
know oh Hollywood liberal like it's like
it would be a lot easier and I would
make a lot more money if I kept my Yap
shut
so I'm not saying I'm I don't want to
I'm not saying I'm a hero but what I'm
saying is don't think that there's
anything in this for me other than than
like a lot of hatred and less money yeah
the Bible is people have to listen like
if somebody doesn't like what you say
they can just go [ __ ] her we're [ __ ]
surprised [ __ ] there's so many other
people they're surprised you the people
that there so many people that can't
separate like the work from that meaning
like they can't you can't just go tell
jokes and they're like okay why don't I
don't agree with the gun stuff but
that's a funny no I I don't know like I
love Katt Williams he's one of my
favorite comedians and then sometimes
they'll say some stuff that I don't
agree with like he I don't know if he
still feels this way but in a special he
talked about like not believing in
evolution good for him like you know it
was like a five minute segment where I
was just kind of like okay and it just
made me think oh I'm really not into
this five minutes but that's I still
like love yeah I don't I don't need I'm
not you're running for president you
don't need our politics don't need to
line up and I'm still allowed to like
you know do what I think is right but
yeah there's so many other movies
there's so many other comics just watch
them right but now they're universally
women you know I'm a girl it's a girl
who likes herself that's disgusting
that's terrifying
are you friends with Hillary Clinton now
I wanna meet her I don't see that for
you okay you're in this position and
people like listen but and if you say
something that they they take it and run
with it whether it's good or bad we
don't like it or don't we're like oh now
everything I say I have to kind of put
through a filter because I'm
people are going to run with it and if I
say something I don't mean then it's out
there and I can't pull it back well I
really try not to say things I don't
mean meaning anymore or something that
could be misinterpreted or anything can
be misinterpreted and what's and really
just lies like just realize we're you
know editing footage like you could do
to any comedian trying to make it look
like right you know like they did
something that they didn't do you regret
anything you've said or know like you
did something that you like [ __ ] I wish
I didn't put that out there I wish I
woulda said that different no honestly
when I look back at roasts like the
Roast of Roseanne was just on it reared
and I I don't I don't think I could do a
roast now like a you know when you're
young and you say mean things like you
know just it's a roast but still like
those people's feelings got hurt I
really wouldn't want to do that to
anyone I'm not really good friends with
like that's why the nature of a roast it
used to be like you know the peers it
was comics but now it's just like random
celebrities and you're just you just
like go for the jugular and it's like I
don't know I wouldn't
I don't regret doing those and they
helped me get sure here but um but I
don't regret trashing Travis no I don't
blame ya and it does hurt yeah it hurts
and it feels good do you regret that do
you feel bad about doing the roast and
saying those things or the backlash that
comes with it like oh no no I actually
like feel bad about you're like if it
actually hurt someone's feelings I feel
bad about that
did you hurt anyone's feelings though
like I guess that arose people do get
hurt but I think most of its I get me if
you don't know someone they think you
mean it some of the women I mean it was
also just a different like like things
have really changed lately obviously and
so you know even like some some jokes
like about other women up there or you
know real like racist stuff whatever
it's it's that's what roasts are but I
don't know I just now I wouldn't do it
now you wouldn't you wouldn't want to do
it did it bother you the Monique in
making trying to make her point kind of
dragged you into it and every time she
was talking about what Netflix was
paying her she kind of you became the
example that's a good question thank you
that's your first ever I've had quite
that point right yeah what about my
question I I really like Monique
and I've like I think she's so funny and
and at first I was yeah I did feel like
kind of bummed that she invoked my name
and it was like I you know my my special
was shot and negotiated so long ago it's
not like I negotiated it like okay and
by giving me this you promise you won't
give monique more you know like but then
she later went on like you know said
that she didn't have any ill-will toward
me and it wasn't that she so like it was
it was disappointing to me at first just
because I'm such a fan of hers um but
then I understood later yeah and it's
just a matter of look if you're putting
if people coming to see you of course
that we have to wrap up in there too by
the way but they're they're uh
you know they're gonna give you money
based on that that's all Netflix gives a
[ __ ] about this right who they think is
gonna make them the most money yeah
they're not like I like you they're
crunching numbers and I'm yeah I had
issues with my money it's so weird I
don't remember this thing where it used
to be like you know that we knew what
people made right but no it's good
because hey happy equal payday guys it's
equal pay today's equal pay what does
that mean does that mean I'm gonna get
paid as much as Jim no it's for equality
of talent at less than Travis equal pay
so I bothered you a little bit at first
but that afterwards not like yeah I just
it at first it hurt my feelings
because I just liked her so much but
then I realized she wasn't really she
wasn't trying to say anything bad about
me she was just you know trying to get
what she felt she desert [ __ ]
anybody call you racist I don't even
understand that nothing that is my I had
jokes that used to be we know I would
play that like that was kind of my
character I would play who would say
like you know dumb racist things but it
was not a character was that like not
you at all it was that you're something
you were doing in the moment or it was a
character it was my stand-up character
like the girl who didn't know that she
was like it awful pretty much and but
then you know you start to be like we
are you laughing at these jokes for the
wrong reasons like this like me making
fun of people who were racist except
people just started laughing at the joke
as if it was just like literal I know
they're like I know right
doing here well dice got a lot of that
we I know we have to wrap up dice got a
lot of that too because of the stuff he
said he's like though I'm doing it like
and it really is amazing because the
people that are trying to get you for
being racist are the same people that
are trying to get you for being like
liberal or whatever they're just trying
to find find something yeah you're fat
you're ugly you're liberal you're you
did this it's and you can see it all in
I feel pretty yeah I hope that uh I hope
that the people who troll me the hardest
find a way to see it because maybe
you'll feel a little bit a little bit
better right yeah I know I think you'll
laugh and you'll you'll come out you'll
go outside it's I it's mainly that
you'll see the Sun